la loi sur la parité n'est pas un cadeau
ou un bonbon offert sur un plateau
d'argent
c'est le symbole d'une longue lutte des
femmes
ce jour là je me suis dit que je n'ai
pas le droit à l'erreur pour deux choses
d'abord parce que je suis une femme et
autres l autre chose c'est parce que
j'étais la plus jeune député
et ici c'est c'est la porte qui mène au
perchoir du président de l'assemblée
nationale donc
g
[Musique]
pour keith homme la jeune génération
nous devons aussi continuer ce travail
l'a fait par les pionnières et c'est le
moment de les remercier ce que si
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes dans les
instances de prise de décision c'est un
parti a dû à ces femmes qui ont bataillé
les femmes une fois élu recherche plus
l'impact que le gain politique pour
servir mon pays aucune ambition et de
trous si demain devenir la première
femme présidente du sénégal oui je suis
prête à
accepter ce challenge là
de façon globale son application affaire
permet vraiment une meilleure
participation politique des femmes à sa
première application en 2012 le sénégal
avait occupé le troisième rang au niveau
africain sur la participation est la
présence des femmes au sein de
l'assemblée nationale alors donc le
sénégal occupe toujours une très bonne
place nous avons espoir que le président
macky sall va continuer à mettre les
femmes au coeur les responsabilités
autant au niveau du gouvernement que
dans les secteurs économiques politiques
je m'étale une hyper v au psg
on
d'accord
il ya eu plusieurs indicateurs qui
montrent que vraiment si on se fait pas
attention la loi peut être remise en
question et chaque fois qu'on a des
acquis nous les femmes il faut toujours
qu'on des plans déploie pardon plus
encore d'énergie pour faire appliquer
mais encore pour faire le suivi il faut
toujours toujours qu'on soit derrière
la loi nous dit que c'est pour les
institutions électives et semi électives
on est en train également de voir
l'autre phase dans les postes nominatifs
ya très très peu de femmes très très peu
de femmes qui sont nommés dans les
gouvernements successifs qui sont nommés
dans les postes de direction et on se
dit mais il ya un problème il va falloir
qu'on se mobilise encore pour nous
battre pour que les femmes compétents
pas seulement les femmes politiques mais
les femmes compétences puissent accéder
à ce poste là